Gauthier le vrai thé à son invité Sarah
Léry secrétaire d'État en charge de la
biodiversité bonjour madame ministre
bonjour vous êtes donc désormais
secrétaire d'État à la biodiversité
d'ailleurs comment on passe du service
national universel à la biodiversité et
bien le présent de la République est la
première ministre m'avait confié d'abord
un des grands défis celui de la nation
celui de permettre à notre pays de
construire un cœur de patriotisme et
d'engagement chez notre jeunesse
objectif accompli 10% d'une classe d'âge
a fait le service national maintenant il
est dans le temps scolaire il est entre
les mains de prise cat Evenou que je
connais très bien et avec Gabriel Attal
que je félicite mèneront à bien la suite
et maintenant le défi du siècle celui de
la biodiversité la question de l'eau la
question de la préservation de nos
espèces mais surtout la préservation de
nos planètes parce que plus que jamais
nous avons besoin de concilier les
vivants et ça ça va être ma mission avec
Christophe Béchu le ministre que je
connais très bien puisque c'est mon
voisin angevin et que je suis très
heureuse de retrouver évidemment on va
en parler sur toute la biodiversité est
en danger autour de la Méditerranée mais
vous disiez objectif atteint concernant
le service national universel l'objectif
c'était aussi de le rendre obligatoire
et ça n'a pas été fait la généralisation
elle a été plus que lancée je rappelle
juste qu'en 2019 c'était 1900 jeunes
cette année on est entre 40 et 50 000
jeunes en tout 80 000 jeunes auront fait
le service national il arrive sur le
temps scolaire de l'année prochaine et
Prisca TV nous ma collègue qui a pris la
suite et bien aura la mission bien sûr
de continuer à apporter à la jeunesse
des réponses jeunesse sur laquelle on
s'appuiera pour les enjeux qui
préservent la planète qui préserve les
espèces et qui préserve ce qu'on a de
plus précieux la nature mais il y avait
énormément de jeunes émeti de mineurs
aussi dans les émotices ça aurait pas
été une bonne chose de rendre ce SNU
obligatoire par exemple pour donner un
cadre à ceux qui ont commis des
exactions pendant les émeutes le service
national universel c'est pas une
punition c'est une chance une chance
d'être français de participer à cette
grande nation et c'est une chance de
m'exciter d'élévation pour le coup du
goût de l'engagement de la
responsabilité individuelle mais ce
n'est pas une punition ça ne sera jamais
ce qui est certain c'est que nous avons
besoin d'unité nous avons besoin de de
cadre de respect des règles et le
service
aurait pu donner un cadre à toute une
jeunesse le débat arrivera certainement
à un moment ou un autre puisqu'il faudra
un débat parlementaire ce sera la
décision de la de l'Assemblée nationale
et du Sénat si c'est son souhait mais
aujourd'hui c'est la mission de ma
collègue presque venue alors même chose
pour essayer de responsabiliser les
jeunes et ceux qui ont commis des
exactions pourquoi avoir rejeté à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est ce qu'a fait
la majorité le principe du casseur
payeur tu casses tu payes jamais la
question ne se posera en termes de rejet
ou pas moi ce que j'ai vu c'est que le
retour au calmement a été rejeté par la
majorité le retour au calme a eu lieu en
5 jours grâce à la mobilisation des
forces de sécurité intérieure policier
gendarme une fermeté des réponses de la
justice parce que le cap était très
clair présent de la République a dit
quoi ordre ordre ordre l'ordre est
revenu maintenant on va aller chercher
la Concorde c'est-à-dire aller en
profondeur responsabiliser les parents
puisqu'il y avait des très grands
mineurs et pour le coup ce n'est pas
acceptable de ne pas aller chercher le
responsabilité stage de parentalité
obligatoire stage de citoyenneté
évidemment vraiment des peines avec de
la prison ferme pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux mais il faut aussi
accompagner ceux qui ont été blessés
dans ce qu'ils sont de ce qu'ils ont
comme engagement je pense évidemment aux
élus locaux je pense évidemment aux
enseignants qui ont vu leurs écoles
parfois détruites entièrement aux
maisons de quartier aux associations qui
ont vu les lieux qui devaient accueillir
un certain nombre de jeunes au quotidien
prendre feu et bien je pense aussi aux
commerçants qui sont accompagnés par
ailleurs il faut réparer c'est pour ça
que la loi sur la avec l'argent des
Français écoutez ça pose la question du
consentement à l'impôt au bout d'un
moment ce qui est certain c'est qu'il
faut réparer pour permettre d'abord la
reprise aider nos aider nos commerçants
on va pas les laisser sur le bord sur le
côté de la route c'est pour ça que les
assureurs ont été mobilisés par le
ministre de l'économie mais on va on va
dire les choses jusqu'au bout
aujourd'hui quand tu quand tu as des
quand tu as quand tu as des actes qui
sont des actes délinquants il y a des
conséquences il y aura des conséquences
pour tout le monde financière y compris
financière il y aura des conséquences
la responsabilité pour les parents et il
faut être très clair on est dans un état
de droit personne n'a le droit de casser
pour aucune raison quelle qu'elle soit
on en vient la fronde dans la police
Sarah elle a écrit est-ce que la place
d'un policier est en détention
provisoire moi je salue je saluerai
toujours le travail des forces de
sécurité intérieure police gendarmerie
très largement ils sont ils sont
l'honneur de notre pays ils sont
toujours été c'est eux qui ont rétabli
l'ordre il faut le rappeler il y a à
peine quelques instants mais personne
n'est au dessus de personne et au-dessus
de la loi ça a été rappelé également je
pense que la justice a besoin de
sérénité pour rendre ses conclusions
plus que jamais en même temps il faut
pas se fâcher avec la police ni avec la
justice donc c'est un espèce de pas de 2
quoi c'est même pas c'est pour le coup
il n'y a pas dans en même temps c'est on
est dans un état de droit ça veut dire
quoi c'est que la loi est la même pour
tous on soutient la police mais personne
n'est au-dessus des lois toujours bien
sûr évidemment c'est c'est les hommes et
les femmes qui au quotidien nous
protègent et font que ces lois sont
respectées et qui est en première ligne
pendant les émeutes mais pendant les
émeutes pendant les attentats pendant en
réalité à chaque fois que notre vidéo
c'est des gardiens de la paix il faut
remettre les choses dans et à côté de ça
et bien il y a des lois et elles sont
valables pour tout le monde et c'est
pour ça que la justice a aussi besoin de
sérénité on sait la féliciter quand les
réponses sont extrêmement fermes pour
les émeutiers je pense que il faut le
calme nécessaire mais surtout moi j'ai
confiance dans nos forces de sécurité
intérieure et dans les policiers en
particulier pour être aux côtés des
Français et des citoyens qui ont le plus
besoin alors vous soutenez bien sûr la
police mais est-ce que vous soutenez les
propos du patron de la police Frédéric
vaut et les propos de leur ennunès
préfet de police qui jugent que la place
d'un policier n'est pas en détention
provisoire n'est pas en prison tant
qu'il n'a pas été jugé tu as vu
aujourd'hui je suis ministre de la
biodiversité et je ne m'amuserai pas à
rentrer dans les commentaires de
commentaires ce qui est certain c'est
que les propos et de l'un et de l'autre
ont une réponse pas de la part du
président de la République et de la
première ministre encore une fois
personne n'est au-dessus de la loi il
faut le retour au calme le randonnez a
fait une lettre aux policiers rappelant
à quel point leur métier est un honneur
un honneur de protéger et que plus que
jamais la priorité qu'est la nôtre c'est
d'être au côté des forces de l'ordre
faut pas faut rappeler que qui a
augmenté le nombre plus de 10000
policiers qui a remis des moyens des
voitures des outils qui a renforcé les
forces de sécurité intérieure c'est nous
qui aujourd'hui a fait une loi de
programmation et pour la justice et pour
le ministère de l'Intérieur qui renforce
le régalien avec le loi de programmation
militaire à plus de 413 milliards
d'euros c'est notre gouvernement donc
évidemment on est au côté des forces de
l'ordre bien sûr mais attention la
justice a aussi besoin de son temps et
puis strict séparation des pouvoirs ne
commande pas l'un ou l'autre et c'est
une erreur de se mettre en arrêt maladie
comme le font les policiers pour se
mettre en grève de manière déguisée et
je rentrerai pas dans ces commentaires
là pour une raison toute simple je pense
qu'on a besoin d'apaisement et j'ai
confiance aujourd'hui dans nos forces de
sécurité intérieure pour répondre et
bien aux missions qui sont les leurs
forces de sécurité qui ont très mal pris
les propos du chef de l'État à Marseille
parlant d'actes inexcusable après la
mort du jeune Naël vous savez encore une
fois moi je suis pas syndicaliste je
suis membre du gouvernement et pour le
coup plus que jamais encore une fois on
rappelle notre soutien aux forces de
sécurité interne et en même temps la
juste séparation des pouvoirs le présent
de la République a plus d'une fois
montré son attachement aux forces de
sécurité intérieure et aux policiers
plus d'une fois et je pense que les
actes le prouve très largement j'ai
parlé du budget entre autres qui n'est
qu'une preuve d'amour le président a dit
qu'il fallait répartir les difficultés
sur l'ensemble du territoire c'était
lors de son interview lundi au journal
de 13h ça veut dire quoi répartir les
difficultés sur le territoire
on a vu que dans certains quartiers il y
a eu il y a eu des violences il y a eu
une période d'extrav de d'ultra violence
avec les émeutes ça a touché d'écarter
populaire mais aussi des villes moyennes
des villes qui n'ont même pas de
quartier populaire il faut un moment
prendre le temps le temps d'une analyse
plus large c'est les travaux qui sont
menés en ce moment même et les
conclusions arriveront à la rentrée
certains à droite notamment répartir les
familles de délinquants sur le
territoire c'est pas ça que ça veut dire
dans dans ce débat là et puis de manière
très claire il y a un ministre en charge
des questions de l'intérieur une
ministre en charge aujourd'hui de la
ville et ce sera à eux bien sûr d'y
répondre par contre je peux vous parler
entre autres des sujets pour le coup des
difficultés qui touchent la question de
biodiversité avec des enjeux
donc c'était intéressant de vous
entendre aussi là dessus vous avez pas
oublié évidemment tout ce que vous avez
fait pendant un engagement est un
engagement pendant même trois ans pour
être exact exactement un an avec
Elizabeth borne avant avec Jean Castex
70% c'est notre sondage du jour c'est la
grille 70 % des Français ne font pas
confiance à Emmanuel Macron pour
rétablir l'ordre dans le pays comment
vous réagissez à cette large majorité de
Français qui craignent qu'Emmanuel
Macron ne rétablissement dans le pays et
on sort d'une période d'ultra violence
on sort d'une d'une période où il y a eu
des pillages des vols des feux qui ont
été allumés et donc moi je comprends
cette cette sensation cette émotion qui
est celle à la suite des violences mais
revenons à la raison qui a donné des
moyens supplémentaires et financiers et
des moyens juridiques c'est notre
majorité notre gouvernement qui est aux
côtés des forces de sécurité intérieure
depuis six ans maintenant c'est notre
gouvernement et notre majorité donc moi
je je ne poserai jamais ce que je vois
c'est des résultats le cap est très
clair donner les moyens à nos à nos
forces régaliennes parce que d'abord
c'est des gardiens de la paix c'est leur
mission il nous protège au quotidien et
de l'autre côté renforcer les moyens de
la justice parce que ça marche sur deux
jambes et on a le budget historiquement
le plus élevé de l'un et de l'autre
aussitôt limogé aussitôt recasé est-ce
que vous savez de qui je parle
[Musique]
je vous laisserai aller au bout de votre
race papa Ndiaye qui donc a été nommé
hier en conseil des ministres
ambassadeurs au Conseil de l'Europe ça
donne quelle image de la politique Sarah
et la grille soyons soyons très très
explicite pas pendiaye a été le milieu
éducation nationale j'ai eu le plaisir
de travailler j'ai eu le plaisir de
travailler avec la majorité j'ai eu le
plaisir de travailler avec lui pendant
plus d'un an à ses côtés parce que vous
avez deux lignes idéologiques assez
opposées quand même vous savez quand on
donne un nom de sa vie pour servir
servir de plein de manières différentes
mais pour servir au sein du gouvernement
c'est une charge c'est une chance mais
c'est une charge c'est une
responsabilité alors on y embarque sa
famille on y embarque ce qu'on a de plus
de plus précieux et on fait de son mieux
ce que j'ai vu c'est un ministre qui a
été à sa tâche et qui aujourd'hui
servira par ailleurs au sein du conseil
au sein du Conseil de l'Europe et je
crois que voilà son expertise
d'universitaire de chercheurs et bien
servira les intérêts de la France au
sein de cet instance mais
bien sûr quand elle fait polémique
plus d'une fois plus d'une fois il y a
eu il y a eu des réponses et ça prouve
bien que jamais ce gouvernement n'est
silencieux quand il faut rappeler
rappeler parfois l'ordre parfois mettre
en lumière des incohérences ou des
injonctions contradictoires du mal à
lutter contre les attentats à la liste à
l'école arrivera à lutter contre ses
campagnes provoles au sein du Conseil de
l'Europe ce qui est certain c'est que
papa N'Diaye pendant un an à servi et
aujourd'hui il continuera à servir être
un peu reconnaissant de l'engagement
c'est pas mal aussi et je du coup je
félicite également du coup mon collègue
Gabriel Attal qui prend la suite on
passe à la biodiversité c'était une
promesse on y va comment protéger notre
biodiversité quand des incendies ravages
le disais les contours de la
Méditerranée vous savez 80% de notre
biodiversité est dans les forêts j'étais
en déplacement hier en Sologne avec Marc
venos sur les questions pour le coup de
forêt plein de manières d'abord
responsabilité et civilité attention
attention
omego dos cigarette attention quand il y
a des interdictions de barbecue ou de
bien
de bien les respecter attention à ce qui
nous entoure parce que faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont en fait
notre patrimoine notre notre patrimoine
dépend des forêts dépend des espèces
dépend des vivants et donc si on ne fait
pas attention si on ne donne pas en
réalité les moyens également et ben aux
forces de lutte contre les incendies je
pensais évidemment nos pompiers qu'on
s'allume pompier professionnel et
pompier volontaire parce que ça pèse
aussi sur l'engagement d'hommes et de
femmes qui se mettent à disposition de
leur territoire alors on met en danger
en réalité notre qualité de vie
évidemment la planète vous êtes l'ami
des chasseurs Sarah la grille vous savez
moi j'aime pour le coup les traditions
et la préservation de la nature je l'ai
toujours je l'ai toujours eu chevillée
au corps je dis ça parce que c'est ce
que vous reproche aymeric Caron à peine
êtes-vous arrivé au secrétariat d'État
de la biodiversité la nupes vous cible
déjà notamment aymeric Caron qui dit que
vous êtes l'ami des chasseurs mais pour
le coup il n'y a aucune il n'y a aucune
il n'y a aucune insulte peut-être dans
sa bouche les gens qui opposent par
exemple Sandrine Rousseau aimerais Caron
ce sont des radicaux qui que en réalité
détruire clivé la réalité elle est où la
réalité elle est dans la qualité du
dialogue moi je suis élu de la
République je suis député de ma
circonscription et Luc locale et bien je
vois autant les associations qui
protègent leurs environnement moi je
pense chez moi évidemment à la
protection des oiseaux de la nature mais
aussi évidemment la Fédération des
chasseurs des pêcheurs et heureusement
qu'on sait se parler discuter travailler
ensemble parce que c'est quoi la
facilité mais monsieur c'est déclamer
des grandes phrases à l'emporte-pièce
depuis Paris ou sur Twitter c'est encore
mieux mais par contre qui qu'ils aillent
sur les territoires qu'il discutent avec
les hommes et femmes qui aiment la
nature profondément et qui l'accompagne
alors vous avez parlé de sonnerie Rosso
elle a fait un tweet contre vous hier
disons parce que vous êtes félicité de
cette brigade antilou deuxième brigade
créée dans l'Aveyron et donc elle dit
comment c'est sa prise de fonction à la
biodiversité par tuer des loups encore
une fois une caricature à
l'emporte-pièce vu de Paris par Madame
morceaux alors ça n'était même personne
c'est la c'est la championne de de la
punchline mais qui ne donne aucune
aucune réponse aucun résultat très
concrètement c'est quoi le sujet présent
de la République a fait une promesse
parce qu'il y a des drames économiques
et pour le coup psychologique qui soit
extrêmement lourd pour les éleveurs
quand il y a des attaques de loups sur
sur leurs élevages moi je suis la
ministre de la biodiversité c'est à dire
que je suis aussi en charge la
préservation d'une espèce c'est le du
look qui est une espèce protégée mais
comment on fait pour faire vivre
ensemble le loup et en même temps nos
éleveurs et bien d'abord on ne les
accompagnant on les aidant à ce que les
indemnités arrivent plus vite en formant
des brigades comme celle de la brigade
du loup qui vont faire des tirs
professionnels en permettant aussi à nos
éleveurs d'avoir des moyens financiers
pour se protéger être indemnisé et faire
attention que l'espèce qui est celle du
loup et bien ne disparaissent pas de
notre planète parce que plus que jamais
nous avons besoin de préserver des
espèces qui sont en danger et donc il y
a des comptages des réponses
scientifiques et ça c'est ma mission
mais c'est beaucoup plus facile de jeter
l'anathème sur l'un ou pour l'autre moi
je comprends le drame que vive nos
éleveurs et nos agriculteurs en
particulier et en même temps ma mission
et bien se trouver le point d'équilibre
l'acceptabilité on gagne pas on gagne
pas en jouant finalement pour le coup à
créer des fractures ça c'est le rôle des
radicaux parce que dans le fond eux ils
cherchent pas de solution moi je crois
que la vidéo fait partie des radicaux
mais bien sûr évidemment mais parce que
elle ne cherche aucune aucun point
d'équilibre ni compréhension de nos
éleveurs et nos agriculteurs ni la
préservation en réalité de l'espèce moi
ma mission elle est autre elle est de
montrer que la biodiversité la
protection de la nature c'est notre bien
commun et donc autour de la table sont
bienvenus tous ceux qui veulent vraiment
faire avancer les choses peu de gens
savent ce qu'il y a derrière
biodiversité la question de l'eau la
question de nos paysages la question des
est la question des espèces protégées
qu'elles soient sur terre ou sur mer la
question de nos abeilles et en réalité
c'est notre bien
le dénoncent par les éoliennes quand ça
c'est la question la question mais bien
sûr la question des paysages aujourd'hui
plus que jamais et dans mon portefeuille
et la question des éoliennes c'est la
question aussi de l'énergie propre et
renouvelable alors moi ma mission c'est
de mettre autour de la table c'est ce
que j'ai fait avec le SMS c'est pour ça
que je suis là après le défi de la
nation le défi du siècle celui de
réussir à mettre et bien autour de la
table une biodiversité une nature une
solution une toute dernière question
pour le moment il y en a eu un hier
encore mais pour le moment la France ne
connaît pas les incendies de l'année
dernière si les terribles incendies de
l'année dernière se reproduisent est-ce
que la France sera prête à faire face
avec suffisamment de pompiers mobilisés
suffisamment de Canadair ma confiance
est totale dans nos services évidemment
de lutte contre les incendies attention
par contre nous avons tous une part de
responsabilité faisons extrêmement
attention en réalité à des accidents qui
amènent à des incendies involontaires le
taux de sécheresse est très élevé on a
vu la caisse je parlais de la question
de l'eau attention vraiment on fait
attention à sa consommation d'eau on
fait attention à ce comment on se
comporte autour aux alentours des
autoroutes également dans les espaces où
c'est très très sec et ensemble on
réussira à passer cet été en tout cas je
l'espère mais surtout les bons réflexes
on fait attention on fait encore
attention et surtout on accompagne les
hommes et les femmes qui luttent contre
le feu au quotidien merci beaucoup
madame la ministre secrétaire d'État à
la biodiversité était l'invité de la
matinale Anthony favalier